my next guest let me just let's just
listen to this for a second because he's
from the American Center foror and
Justice
yooo let's hear it for the American
Center for Law in Justice they filed the
lawsuit against Bloomberg dimberg
Bloomberg when his when when his toolbox
Bloomberg's toolbox at the Landmark
commission voted unanimously to deny
Landmark status to a 150y old building
Daniel Badger and by the way whenever
they tell you that it's 600 feet from
ground zero this is your response
lie that building is Ground Zero that
building was hit and partially destroyed
by the planes that went into those
Towers there were human remains in that
building that building is Ground Zero
why there I ask you why there why such a
deliberately provocative act but I'm
going off on a tangent my next speaker
is Jordan seculo of the wonderful and
righteous American Center for Law and
Justice and he is with us
now thank you
Pam hello
America you know I want to start with
this we represent a first responder
we've actually filed a lawsuit to stop
the Moss that wants to go right here at
Ground Zero
he said this on our radio show two days
ago he said Imam rouf is trying to
extort America on the back of my dead
friends that is our client he is taking
a stand I want to tell you something
about the American Center for Law and
Justice we have firsthand experience
with Sharia law we have an office in
Israel but the first case we handled was
for a Palestinian Christian in Gaza her
husband who ran the only bookstore that
sold Bibles in Gaza City was killed by
Hamas in the
street no
justice no court date and yet this
Imam refuses to call an
organization who killed a pregnant woman
last week in Israel and rushed to claim
responsibility he refuses to call them a
terrorist organization Imam Roth Amer
America rejects you we reject you and we
reject your ground zero
mosque it's it's amazing what comes out
of this man's mouth and we've heard all
about the blood on our hands on American
hands he forgets Kuwait he forgets what
we've done around the world he forgets
that organizations like the American
Center for Law and Justice when we win a
case at the Supreme Court and we win a
lot of them when we win them it's for
everybody who's religious in the country
not just Christians not just Jews but
Muslims too in fact you could say that
the aclj has done more for the Muslim
Community in America than most
organizations in the United States but
we understand that with the great
responsibility of religious freedom in
our country and this great right you
have to make the right decisions and it
is not right to put a mosque here at a
place where this
Imam this week said it's not sacred
ground America are you standing on
sacred ground right
now the blood is not on our hands never
accept that terrorist threat because
that's what it is see in the United
States when someone says oh if you don't
let me build our building we're going to
attack you
you know what we say we will fight you
we will fight you and we're not
afraid see Imam
R the blood's not on our hands the blood
is on your
hands he is the man who has gone around
the world talking about how our soldiers
have killed more innocent Muslims than
alaa has of innocent non-muslims that is
reading from Al qaeda's
suicide bomber recruitment handbook
that's what this Imam does and we can't
be afraid and that's why I'm telling you
today from the American Center for Law
and
Justice we are going to fight this
aggressively not just screaming about it
but they're going to
court but I have to say
this it's because of you because when
the news media said oh no no the
American people they're not going to
come to a rally on 911 look how many
people are here media look at us
patriotic
Americans and then they said no the
people of New York they support the
mosque and then they did their own polls
and guess what happened they
don't and then they pulled the American
people and realize where people like the
New York Times are with their op-eds and
editorials telling us how racist we are
71% of the country disagrees with them
and about 22% of their City still even
cares what they say we're ready to
fight but I need you to stand with
us and it's not for the
AJ it's for the First Responders it's
for the 911 families it's for the people
of New York the people of Washington and
Pennsylvania but it's really for all of
the American people we will stand up
against extremist
and we will fight them
aggressively every way we
can I want to say this
today we will never allow this Ground
Zero mosque no
mosque no MK no MK God Bless America
thank you very much